c'est autour de ce complexe industriel
métallurgique que les combats se sont
concentrés ces derniers jours aux abords
de la ville portuaire de marioupol sur
ces images ce sont les troupes russes
que l'on voit assisté par les soldats
tchétchènes ce mercredi les forces
russes ont annoncé la réédition d'une
partie significative des soldats
ukrainien jusque-là retranchés dans
cette zone
à marioupol dans la zone de l'usiné
métallurgique ilitch à la suite
d'opérations offensive des forces armées
russes et de la milice de la dynamique
de donetsk 1026 militaire de la 36e
brigade marine ont volontairement déposé
les armes et se sont rendus
une information démentie par kiev qui
indique que les forces ukrainienne
résiste toujours notamment dont les sous
terrains du complexe industriel le
contrôle de cette ville stratégique du
sud est de l'ukraine serait une victoire
pour les forces russes il leur
permettrait de consolider leur emprise
sur les côtes du craignent n le long de
la mer d'azov en reliant la région du
dombass en partie contrôlé par les pro
russe à la crim est annexée en 2014 et
de poursuivre l'offensive vers l'est et
le nord
de nombreux civils ukrainiens sont
toujours coincés dans les ruines de
marioupol assiégée et bombardée depuis
40 jours détruite à plus de 90% mardi le
gouverneur ukrainien de la région de
donetsk a annoncé qu'entre 20 et 22
mille personnes sont mortes dans la
ville